Цей будинок у Москві - одна з кількох будівель, що постраждали
від атаки безпілотників рано вранці 30 травня.
Внаслідок влучення дрона було зруйновано фасад будинку
та повибивало шибки на верхніх поверхах.
Місцеві кажуть, що чули "бавовну".
Десь вранці, о 4 ранку, пролунав просто
оглушливої сили удар. Дуже сильний, більш схожий
на сильний удар грому дуже близько.
Звичайно, це буде знову. Навіть хлопці, які це роблять,
вони ж прямим текстом сказали, що це буде і буде.
В кожному разі, цей безпілотник, він летів не в цей будинок,
швидше за все. Найімовірніше він летів у центр:
або на міністерство оборони, або до Кремля, або ще кудись,
адже видно, що він потрапив у верхівку будівлі,
він просто випадково вляпався.
О 4:15-4:30 дуже сильний удар, навіть вибух.
Аж підскочили з дружиною, вікна виходять на один, на інший бік.
Подивилися з одного й іншого боку, нічого не видно,
та й далі спати лягли.
Робітники, які працювали вночі, кажуть, що приблизно о 4-й ранку
був удар такий, що вони, хто там відпочивав,
мало з ліжка не попадали.
Тобто був дуже гучний вибух. "Хлопок".
Як стверджують у міноборони Росії, Москву атакували
вісім безпілотників і начебто п'ять дронів були збиті у Підмосков'ї,
ще три нейтралізували засобами радіоелектронної боротьби,
внаслідок чого вони цитата "втратили управління
і відхилилися від намічених цілей".
Натомість російські телеграм-канали пишуть, що Москву
атакували понад два десятки дронів,
п'ять з яких збили над елітним районом Рубльовка.
У Кремлі заявили, що Путін вирішив не звертатися до москвичів
через атаку безпілотників. При цьому на міноборони Росії
накинувся ватажок ПВК "Вагнер" Євген Пригожин,
який давно конфліктує з міністром оборони РФ Сергієм Шойгу
та начальником генштабу РФ Валерієм Герасимовим.
В атаці безпілотників на Москву міноборони Росії
звинуватило Україну. В офісі ж президента України стверджують,
що Київ не має прямого відношення до атаки.
Ви знаєте, ми ж втягуємося в еру штучного інтелекту.
Можливо, не всі дрони готові атакувати Україну,
і хочуть повернутися до своїх творців і відповідним чином
поставити запитання: "А навіщо ви нас відправляєте бити
по дітях України, по Києву і так далі".
До штучного інтелекту ми маємо відношення, а до атак...
Ну, ми з задоволенням дивимося - і прогнозуємо збільшення
кількості атак. Але, звичайно, прямого відношення не маємо.
На думку експертки з питань безпеки лондонського Кінгс-Коледжу,
зараз кожна сторона конфлікту намагатиметься пояснити те,
що сталося, якнайвигідніше для себе.
З одного боку, це може бути операція під чужим прапором,
що означає, що за атакою безпілотників у такому разі,
швидше за все, стоять російські спецслужби,
що зміцнило б наратив Росії та необхідність продовження
так званої спеціальної військової операції.
З іншого боку, ми також чули заяву голови української військової
розвідки Буданова, який каже про відповідь України
на нещодавні атаки безпілотників на Київ.
Це означає, що українська сторона також була б зацікавлена
показати, що вона може оминути російську протиповітряну оборону
та досягти серця Москви чи Кремля.
На початку травня два дрони також атакували московський Кремль.
У Києві тоді також відкинули звинувачення Москви.
І така поведінка - практично стандартна практика з обох боків,
зазначає британський військовий експерт Майк Мартін.
І це сягає того часу, коли у Росії були маленькі "зелені чоловічки" в Криму,
і вона говорила, що не має до них жодного відношення.
А Україна впродовж усієї війни, коментуючи різні диверсійні місії
чи атаки, фактично говорила: "О, ми нічого про це не знаємо".
Проте атака дронів швидше за все свідчить про активізацію
бойових дій, зазначає австрійський політолог,
професор з міжнародних відносин
в Університеті Інсбрука Ґергард Манґотт.
Українська сторона, очевидно, хоче принести жах війни
і до столиці. Росіянам хочуть дати зрозуміти, що держава
не здатна захистити їх ні у прикордонних регіонах, ні у Москві.
І це підриває амбіції Путіна, а саме: створити в російському суспільстві
враження, що жодної війни немає, що все начебто нормально.
Експерт звертає увагу, що, за словами прессекретаря Кремля,
президент Росії Володимир Путін не планує звертатися
до громадян країни у зв'язку з атакою безпілотників на Москву.
Хоча насправді він міг би сказати населенню:
дивіться, наскільки важлива боротьба з Україною,
вона тероризує вас, цивільне населення.
Але, на думку Путіна, я думаю, це ще гірше - транслювати щось подібне,
бо це зробило б очевидним, що російська протиповітряна оборона
працює погано, і що держава не в змозі захистити
населення у Москві. Тому він вважає за краще мовчати.
Використання безпілотників має велике значення у цій війні,
зазначають експерти. Як для розвідки, так і для завдання ударів
по цілях на землі. Який тип зброї був використаний
для удару по Москві? Експертам поки що важко дати однозначну відповідь.
На цьому етапі дуже важко визначити походження дронів,
і я думаю, що буде багато туману, коли справа дійде до типів дронів.
В ніч на вівторок сталася чергова атака безпілотників і на Україну.
ЗСУ повідомляють про щонайменше 31 дрон-камікадзе.
За даними українських військових,
над Києвом було збито 29 з них.